when things get really dark and times
are really hard there's something about
harry potter that makes life richer it's
a strong bond that we'll always have
[Music]
we're family and we will always be part
of each other's life that's an emotional
emma watson in the first official
trailer for harry potter 20th
anniversary return to hogwarts it feels
kind of emotional actually the actress
along with co-stars daniel radcliffe and
rupert grint revisits the sets of the
eight film series and reminisce about
their filming 20 years after the release
of the first film in 2001 and as
expected it was magical i think this is
the perfect time to sit down with
everyone and reminisce
[Music]
the thing that scared me the most
was the implication that the most
meaningful thing in our life was done
and there's something so joyous about
seeing everyone
and be like
there wasn't though it's also the first
time the gryffindor trio will be joined
by their castmates from across the
series yep that includes their slytherin
foe draco malfoy it feels like no time
has passed
and loads of times past we do stay in
touch um
quite frequently really or not so um
it's nice that we're always in four
different corners of the earth and yet
when we catch up it feels like
yesterday that this was all going on and
um it's really really um
touching and sweet i think the
anniversary special also features
appearances from other memorable members
of the potterverse including helena
bonham carter one of the highlights of
my part was when i had to pretend to be
hermione pretending to be better trick i
don't like to be kept waiting i've still
got the teeth actually i'll put them in
if you want and it wouldn't be a reunion
without the dark lord himself ray finds
aka voldemort my sister has children who
have been around 10 11 12. and i said
math i don't know about this voldemort
what you're being asked to play
voldemort
you've got to do it potterheads will
have to wait until the new year to see
the special though it drops on hbo max
january 1st but in the meantime e.t got
the scoop from harry potter fave rupert
grint who spilled even more details
about the emotional reunion what was it
like for you and daniel and emma to to
come back was it emotional and
uh maybe who got the most emotional at
all what can the fans expect oh yeah i
mean definitely there's there's emotions
it's
those um movies where our childhood we
grew up on those sets so it has
incredible meaning to all of us i think
and to see each other again i think it
was i think it's ten years since we
wrapped the last movie and i mean we've
seen each other quite a bit
between but not not a great deal so it
was
it was great to see them again and
kind of
talk about it because it's not something
i really
can't even think about a lot so it's
it's it's nice to be
kind of reintroduced to it and and to
remember because it was it was an
amazing time it was it was great fun any
secrets revealed
um
well no i'm not sure how much i could
say but it's
it's uh
it's i don't know i can't really say
before but it's
it's every everyone everyone's there
so it's um
it seems like it's gonna deliver
yeah yeah
absolutely rupert also reveals if he
would be down to reprise his role as ron
weasley now that he's a dad himself
there's been a lot of talk of that
recently with everything going on um
so yeah i mean it's
i have a
very i mean i feel like i am that
character i have a very
strange relationship in life i feel like
he is kind of
me there's a lot of me in there so it's
i'm quite protecting him so i think yeah
i mean
yeah absolutely i don't really have a
good reason
to say no it's i'm very proud to be a
part of those movies